nathan is with us in Bowling Green
Kentucky hi Nathan how are you I'm doing
pretty good today
yeah it's Friday I redid they better
than I deserve sir how can I help I have
just filed bankruptcy this last year
before I started listening to I just
started listening to you about two weeks
ago and I really wish I would have heard
of you before then my question for you
is I have a credit card that I got after
my bankruptcy to try to reestablish my
credit and it's a $300 limit and I have
it already like I can pay it off in one
check it's not that it's a manageable
but should I cut it up and start away or
what should I do with it
there's a word baby step 1 mm-hmm okay
well like you said Nathan you're kind of
new to all of this and what I teach is
and the way I've lived my life after I
filed bankruptcy at 28 years old
30 years ago is I quit borrowing money
for anything
yeah and for that reason I didn't need a
credit score what about buying a house I
mean one day we want to buy our own
house how do we establish our credit or
I can use my VA loan you won't want to
use a VA loan it's a more expensive loan
you'll want to use a conventional Fannie
Mae loan it's a better deal and you know
it'll be about four years from the time
of your bankruptcy was dismissed before
you'll be able to qualify for a
traditional mortgage and regardless of
how much credit you build or don't build
when you get ready to do that if you've
had four years of paying your landlord
earlier on time you're steady on your
job and you have a good strong down
payment you can get a mortgage without a
credit score and you'd have a bankruptcy
there in your past obviously and but
you're not going to offset a chapter 7
bankruptcy in four years running up
credit cards and you know your scores
not gonna flip on you for that so you
you do what we call in the mortgage
business a man you
underwriting which is if I were to go
get a mortgage and I'm a
multi-millionaire but I'm not gonna go
get a mortgage but if I were I would
have to do manual underwriting because I
don't have a credit score or my credit
score zero because I have a lot of money
in 30 years and so that that's the goal
but cause you're number one wealth
building tool is your income and you
don't want to go back in debt it just
got you bankrupt yeah so I mean dad
hasn't worked good for you you know
brother's wife and I scared huh it's got
my wife and I scared and looking at it
as a debt and wondering if we're gonna
get back into debt because I mean we
already got a $12,000 hospital bill and
things are already piling back up on us
and I mean I have a good job but it's
just kind of scary getting back into
this you know what do you guys make I
went last year for making thirty eight
thousand and I just got a new job
driving truck I'm making sixty thousand
this year good does she work outside the
home she's working on her disability mmm
okay she's got medical issues I'm sorry
okay all right you know and so what how
old do you guys I'm 32
she's gonna be 35 this year okay all
right well we well I can told you we
were 28 when we hit the wall so let's do
this let's give you the tools so you
don't have to live with this this money
thing hanging over your head we need to
make you need to make money behave and
tell it what to do instead of wondering
when all the time I'm gonna pay for you
to go through through our class
Financial Peace University if I pay for
it will you to go definitely okay thank
you yeah you need you need to have those
all the different pieces of tools in
your belt to be able to fight this and
win and you know the credit card yeah
we're going to cut that up and get you a
debit card and no we're not going to
worry about building your credit because
credit has not been your friend and
instead we're going to take this
wonderful income you have and then
and her money comes and so forth then
we'll be able to know what to do with it
every dollar is gonna have an assignment
and you're gonna build wealth from this
point forward